>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Rob Casper: Hey everyone thanks
for coming out on the lovely,
lovely day in D.C. I'm Rob
Casper, thanks to Mary Ann
and to Diane Abraham and everyone
here at Nichols Center Staff
for this wonderful series.
We couldn't be happier
that they host us here.
Ron reminded us this
is our 15th event.
It's gotten to the
point where I feel
like we have all the various rituals
that we have, including me getting
up on the stage and maybe
we'll actually have a stretch
at some point for those of you
who have been here a
lot, you're used to it.
Ron is an amazing guy.
What Ron does with our --
>> Move it along.
>> Rob Casper: Just blows my mind.
I'm not going to say anything
more, because he won't let me.
Let me tell you a little
bit about the poetry center
at the Library of Congress.
We are home to the [Inaudible]
consultant and poetry.
We also put on all sorts of
programs throughout the year.
We have two great programs
coming out on the 20th
of April we have our
[Inaudible] reading
with [Inaudible] this
year Claudine Marankin
and who is the other, Nate Mackie.
They make a fabulous pair.
And on the 26th our [Inaudible],
that includes all sorts of stuff,
I can't tell you about
until tomorrow.
If you want to find out
more about our programs,
you can visit our website
www.loc.gov/poetry.
I also just wanted to
mention you all see this here?
Its a little survey,
you should have it.
If you don't mind filling
it out after the event
and let us know how we
did, that would be perfect.
And now I want to introduce Dana
Levin, our 2016-2017 series.
Dana grew up in California's
Mojave Desert and earned a BA
from Pitzer College and an
MA from New York University.
Her collections of poetry
include "In the Surgical Theater",
"Wedding Day", "Sky
Burial" and "Banana Palace',
which was published last
year by Canyon Press, thanks.
>> Rob Casper: Selecting
Levin's manuscript
for the American Poetry Review
[Inaudible] praised the work
as "sensuous, compassionate,
violent, extravagant".
In the Surgical Theater, also in the
John C. Zacharis First Book Award,
the Ploughshares and
the PEN/Osterweil Award.
In 2014, then the US Poet Laureate
selected Dana Levin for fellowship
from the Library of Congress.
Levin's many other
honors include fellowships
from Guggenheim foundation,
the National Dow for the Arts,
the Rona Jaffe Foundation
and the Whiting Foundation.
She previously taught at
the University of Mexico,
Santa Fe University of Art and
Design and the college of Santé Fe.
She currently serves as the
distinguished writer and residence
at Marysville University,
and she just moved
or is about to [Inaudible]
St. Louis, Missouri.
So, please join me in
welcoming Dana Levin.
[ Applause ]
>> Ron Charles: I'm so glad
you're here, thank you for coming.
>> Dana Levin: My pleasure.
>> Ron Charles: We discovered we
have three things I common already.
We both love poetry, we
both work in St. Louis
and we're both Buffy
the Vampire fans.
>> Dana Levin: Yes, definitely.
>> Ron Charles: Not the
weirdest coincidence.
When I first came to the post
in 2005 one of my jobs was
to edit a column we used
to have called the Poets
Choice, a much beloved column.
And Robert Pinsky was the
poet and one of his columns;
this was the first few
months that I was here.
One of his poems was
explaining what an image is.
He wrote, "Images can be
satisfactorily clear in one way,
and excitingly inexplicable
in another".
Here's an example he said.
And then he published
one of your poems.
Probably the first
poem of yours I read.
>> Dana Levin: Wow.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
"Six monarch butterfly
cocoons clinging
to the back of your throat".
Will you read the rest of
that or the whole part?
>> Dana Levin: Sure.
Ours poetica.
Six monarch butterfly cocoons
clinging to the back of your throat.
You could feel their
gold wings trembling.
You were alarmed.
You felt infested.
In the downstairs bathroom
of the family home,
gagging to spit them out.
And a voice saying, "Don't, don't".
>> Ron Charles: No for Pinsky
that was an example of an image
that makes you feel something
that you wouldn't feel
through any kind of
literal description.
Talk about how an image
works for you?
What an image does for you?
>> Dana Levin: I would
say an image is a portal
for realization and discovery.
So, I have always had what
I call image fascination.
Whether I'm looking at art or seeing
something in the world or something
that comes into my inner eye.
My dreams are very visual.
I pay a lot of attention to
these images and especially
in my early life as a poet;
the poems almost always began
with an image that I
couldn't get out of my head.
And often times the act of writing
the poem was why can I not get this
image out of my head.
And so in entering the
image, the image just sort
of became a constellation
usually of all sorts of material.
And you know there's a
psychotherapeutic idea
that the symbol is
the most economic way
to communicate very complicated
contradictory constellations
of information.
So, which is something I believe.
>> Ron Charles: And do.
>> Dana Levin: Or try.
>> Ron Charles: There are images
that make us see something
literal, much more clearly.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: But that's
not what that image was?
>> Dana Levin: No,
actually sometimes
when the image unfolds it's more
mysterious than it even was before.
>> Ron Charles: But
it gives you a feeling
that no literal explanation
could invoke in you.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: When
I was teaching English
and Poetry I would have
students, and maybe you do too,
although your students
are probably older.
And they would say "Well why doesn't
the poet just say what she wants
to say.
Why encode it and then
make us uncode it"?
Do you ever hear that?
>> Dana Levin: Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
>> Ron Charles: You make a sarcastic
crack in one of your poems.
You say "We are getting such
lovely flourishes from our poets.
What's your answer to that student?
>> Dana Levin: Gosh, well first
I would probably say the world
is complicated.
The world is not easily
understandable.
>> Ron Charles: Why make
it worse with poetry then?
>> Dana Levin: Well
because of that experience,
you know having the
experience of discovery,
which means you have
to wade through things.
Now not everybody has tolerance -
well everybody has a different level
of tolerance for how much
time they want to spend wading
through information, or not
information, let's say an image.
And poetry, one of the reasons why
it's such a subversive art form is
that it has the capacity to
really ask you to just slow down,
and be with your discomfort
and your uncertainty
and you're not knowing
and your confusion.
And one of the things I always
tell my students is I got this
from the critic, Helen Vendler who
said, "Instead of reading a poem
and saying "What does this
poem mean" it's better
for the first question to be either
"How does this poem make me feel"
or "How does the speaker
of the poem seem to feel"?
And I think that 80 to 90%
of the time you can tell
what the feeling is even
if you are not quite certain
what the narrative sense is
or the intent is and
that kind of stuff.
>> Ron Charles: And
you may never get that.
>> Dana Levin: You may never get it.
>> Ron Charles: In one of your poems
you write, "I would be disingenuous
if I said "Being understood
were not important to me".
Between the ceiling of private dream
and the floor of public speech,
between the coin and the hand it
crosses, mercantilists and governors
and preachers alike, the
imagination and its product
so often rebuff purpose and some
of us don't like it and wanted
to make it mean, I would
never shoot you even
if you were the only meat around".
[ Laughter ]
>> Ron Charles: I love it because it
so demonstrates what you're doing.
I'm with you right at that top line.
It's totally explicit.
I know exactly what
you mean and then
by the end you have the surprising
witty metaphor that is arresting
and surprising and funny.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Tell me more.
>> Dana Levin: About that poem?
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Dana Levin: So actually
this poem came out of -
I have a long correspondence
with a poet named GC Waldrep.
And well I'm somebody who
hoards scraps and failed poems
and journal entries and
I'm constantly going back
into that material and seeing
if I can smash it together
and make something happen with it.
And with this poem I just
started to like how I sounded
when I was writing to GC
because it seemed like language
that didn't often make
it into my poems.
So, I actually took about 25
pages of our correspondence
and I just started to highlight
anything that didn't sound
like how I usually sound.
And the I whittled down to
10 pages and I whittled it
down to three pages and then - so
these are all things I said to GC.
>> Ron Charles: Excellent.
And how important is it to
you really to be understood?
>> Dana Levin: Well, it's
going to sound ridiculous.
This is probably the
torture of all poets.
It's deeply important to me.
>> Ron Charles: Because you
are the - and I say this
with complete respect,
you are a difficult poet.
>> Dana Levin: My mother
would agree.
>> Ron Charles: You're worth
it; you're totally worth it.
>> Dana Levin: Thank you.
>> Ron Charles: But it's not two
roads you know diverged in a wood.
>> Dana Levin: No, I mean I -
yeah and it's actually a current
despair at mid-life, it is.
You're like "What am I doing".
Shouldn't I just say it?
But I - what I tell my students,
I keep going back to this
because I feel like this is
where I articulate my thought
that I don't even know I think.
But I told my students that you -
and you have to determine what
your relationship is to a reader.
And for myself it's poem by
poem; so there's certain poems
where I'll just love a
weirdness that's developing
or a turn a phrase
that's developing.
And I know that somebody else
may not necessarily understand
or get what I see in it.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dana Levin: But because of the
tactile quality of the language
or the image I just
want to preserve it.
And so then I'm just like "Meh
the reader can figure it out".
And then there's other [Inaudible]
if I'm successful at those moments
of clarity or not, but and I
love mystery, and I love puzzles
and I love being disturbed
by something
and not knowing why I'm disturbed.
And so that quality I think
comes back into the poems
and I guess a reader of my work
will either like being in that state
or will be like I'm throwing
this book across the room.
>> Ron Charles: I'm sure
that does not happen often.
There's a poem you've
written called "Last Heart",
which is a poem about
teaching poetry.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
I haven't read this
poem in maybe 15 years.
>> Ron Charles: Are there any
words you can't pronounce?
>> Dana Levin: Who knows?
We're going to find out.
Tell me if I'm laughing too loud.
And this poem ended up - there's
stuff about my grandparents
that came into this poem
that I didn't expect.
>> Ron Charles: It's surprising
as a reader when you hit it.
>> Dana Levin: Okay.
Glass Heart.
"Could the west creep into
your idea of happiness?
Abundance, which gave no comfort,
in which your loneliness was spared.
The student wrote, she
wipes tears from her heart.
Forgotten on the kitchen table,
glassy, beaded with sweat.
"The line is too sentimental"
said the teacher unless I see
it literally.
Taking a sponge to
the anatomical heart,
wiping and wiping the tears off it.
Glass heart, so transparent.
The tears drove around its Autobahn.
Then the kids came home
and found it pulsing there,
like in a washing machine.
You could see the grief
go round and round.
The student wrote, "Sucking tears
out of her aorta with a straw".
A bitterness so pronounced
it was kind of ammonia.
A world in which one
could lose one's parents
and be put on a train alone.
Her grandfather had owned
a little store for years.
They can shoot out the windows
he would say wagging a finger,
as long as they don't
set the street on fire.
Glass heart, so transparent.
Was it their mothers, their fathers?
It lay weeping in the heat.
But they had to leave to
help deliver groceries.
The student wrote "In
my left, my heart.
My right, my bone.
Beating my heart like
a bloody drum".
Ovens the grandfather muttered,
in Russia they ate us raw.
So, transparent.
Meal after meal no one claimed it.
After a while no one saw it.
Though it ticked at the center of
the table like a clock, singing oh,
this sack of water swaying
on its hook of bone.
>> Ron Charles: That makes me
want to teach poetry again.
Because what the poem does
so brilliantly is demonstrate
you teaching poetry,
while teaching us poetry.
You move from the students
flat, cliché,
bland images to your own
arresting, surprising images.
Moving back and forth.
It's a little more clear
when you read it yourself,
parts are in italics and set off.
But I think you read it in a
way that we could follow it.
>> Dana Levin: Oh good.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
Too sentimental, unless
I see it literally.
How does that guide
your work generally?
>> Dana Levin: Well you know -
>> Dana Levin: For myself, like for
instance I remember auditing a class
with Charles Simmick when I
was in my 20's and he went off
on how the moon was a dead symbol.
And I was insulted.
I was 22. I wanted to
write about the moon.
How can the moon be a dead symbol?
But I think what he was trying
to say was that you know,
how many poems have
had the moon in it?
And later it made me - as I was like
reading actually a lot of Haiku,
I was thinking about the
Haiku masters and how
for them the classic Haiku
masters like Basho and Issa.
Their mastery was displayed by
how well they worked variations
of tropes, like if you were going
to write a Haiku about autumn,
you had to have the harvest moon in
it, or you had to have cider in it
or these things called Keego.
And this idea about variation
rather than originality,
the west is very focused
on I'm going
to invent something out of nothing.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dana Levin: Which of
course doesn't ever happen.
>> Ron Charles: It
gets harder and harder.
>> Dana Levin: I don't think
anything is source less,
so the Haiku masters were really
interesting to read about in terms
of that it wasn't about - that the
originality was inside variation.
So I feel like the -
I'm going around this.
This is what usually happens to me.
If I want to write a poem about the
moon and I'm trying to avoid all
of the clichés about the moon, or
if I want to write about the heart.
This is even better, and I
want to avoid all the clichés
about the heart, well most of the
clichés about the heart have to do
with sentimentality or kind
of modeling feeling or cutesy
or so for me the best way to
bypass that was to actually look
at the anatomy of the heart.
I actually got a book - I actually
got Grey's Anatomy when I was
in grad school and I wanted
to actually look at the heart.
And could I bring that language,
that anatomical language back
into the image of a heart and
somehow renew it for myself.
And also do other weird things
to it like a glass heart,
that has an Autobahn inside it.
If you think about blood cells -
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Dana Levin: Blood
cells moving through -
>> Ron Charles: A washing machine.
>> Dana Levin: Exactly;
yeah, why not?
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dana Levin: Don't you want to put
your heart in the washing machine?
There's many of us
who would benefit.
[ Laughter ]
>> Ron Charles: Does it
work with the students?
Do they see that?
Can they hear how startling that is
compared to their own bland word?
>> Dana Levin: In defense
of my students,
I've had really amazing
students in my time.
I don't think talent
is a rare commodity.
I think discipline
is a rare commodity
and vocation is just
something that happens.
But I think talent is everywhere.
Yeah with some students, yes.
But sometimes you have
to trick them.
Like you have to trick them
into discovering their own
idiosyncratic vividness and that's
where exercises, assignments
and stuff can be really helpful
to get them to have to skirt
around what they think a poem is.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Dana Levin: Or what
they think a poem can do.
>> Ron Charles: We
have so much language
on the shelves just
waiting to be brought -
>> Dana Levin: Absolutely.
>> Ron Charles: Like last
week's shirts and worn again.
Read a poem about poetry.
You write really good
poems about poetry.
>> Dana Levin: Thank you.
When this book came out
some people were unhappy
that there were poems about poetry.
Well it was kind of fashionable to
write poems about poetry during -
>> Ron Charles: I've read
a lot about - of them
and I think yours are
really exceptional.
I can't pronounce this title.
>> Dana Levin: Quelque chose.
>> Ron Charles: What does that mean?
>> Dana Levin: It's
French for something.
It's kind of -
>> Ron Charles: That's
not very helpful at all.
>> Dana Levin: It's - if
anybody here speaks French,
please correct me if I am incorrect.
It's kind of like a French
version of whatever, sort of.
Is that correct?
>> Yes.
>> Dana Levin: Excellent.
I think there's also
a cuss word in here.
>> Ron Charles: There are some,
its okay; we're all adults here.
>> Dana Levin: The entire
field of language is available.
Okay. Quelque chose.
"You want to get in and
then get out of the box.
Form, breakage, form.
I was at the fish shop wondering why
being experimental means not having
a point.
Why experimentation in form
is sufficient unto itself.
Is it? But I needed a new way
to say things, sad, tired,
I with its dulled violations,
lyric with loss in its faculty den.
Others were just throwing a veil
over suffering, glittery,
interesting.
I don't exist.
All over town I marched
around ranting my jeremiad.
Thinking what good is form
if it doesn't say anything?
Any by say, I mean wake somebody up.
Even here at the shores
of Lake Champlain mothers were
wrenching small arms out of sockets.
Not just the mothers.
What were the fathers doing,
wrenching small arms
out of bedside caches?
How could I disappear into language
when children were being called
fuckers by their mothers?
Who were being called
cunts by their boyfriends?
dickheads, behind their backs?
It wasn't that I was
a liberal Democrat;
it was that bodies had been
divested of their souls like poems.
Trying to get in or out of the box.
And the scallops said "Neulle
idees que dans les choses."
And I said "I'll have
the Captain's special
with wedges instead of fries".
And everywhere in the fish
shop the argument raged,
its baroque proportions.
The conflict between
harmony and invention.
But then brilliance, the
movement of her gloved hands
as she laid the haddock
out one by one.
The sheer transparency of
her latex fingers in and out
of the lit displayed case
as if they were yes, fish.
Laying haddock out in a
plastic tub on a bed of ice.
Her lank brown hair pulled
back from her ace with a band.
Yes it was true she had
to do this for the market,
but there was such beauty in it.
She was the idea called tenderness.
She was a girl who stood
under fluorescent lights
making six bucks an hour.
And she looked up at me
and held out a haddock
with both her hands saying it was
the best of the mornings catch.
Neule idees que dans les choses
is a French version for no ideas,
but in things which we get
from William Carlos Williams.
And this was my poem
against [Inaudible].
I don't think anybody knows.
Now I've told you.
>> Ron Charles: It does seem
like a pretty broad attack
on the blandness of modern poetry.
>> Dana Levin: Well yeah or just
the idea - this book was written
at a moment when poetry
world was very enamored
of what we now call
the elliptical poem.
It seems so dated now actually.
The world has moved in
such interesting ways.
But after 50 years of the
hegemony, of the confessional poem
and plain style confessional
poetry, suddenly people remembered
about the tactility of
language which was exciting.
And ideas about post structural
philosophy started to come in
and mess up people's minds.
There is no author text, speak
to other text, blah, blah, blah.
So, I found this poetry, this -
a lot of the time surfaces
were gorgeous
and fascinating and they were empty.
>> Ron Charles: They didn't
wake anyone up as you say?
>> Dana Levin: They
didn't wake anyone up,
so that poem was a direct response
and all the French is in there
because I was mad at [Inaudible].
>> Ron Charles: And you say how
can you write poems like that
that are just experimental but are
just clever, that are fascinating.
When so many people around
you are physically suffering.
>> Dana Levin: Yes, today
that poetry will go nowhere
because we're in a different moment.
It's very interesting
to be alive for a while
and see this stuff change.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
Let's talk about the
body and the soul.
Many of your poems explore these
profound and ancient questions
between the material body, which
you call throughout your books meat
and the soul.
The soul that crammed a dark thing
in the body, bitten and chained.
In another poem you write "Mine's
an accident of bio-wiring",
that's one line of thinking.
We're animals that shit out
consciousness, that's another.
It's frequently an impatience to
be disembodied in your poetry.
You write in one, who will
help me avoid my meat suit?
Your latest book opens
with the ironic lines
"We used our texting machines to
look up the definition of soul".
>> Dana Levin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: You
didn't find it there?
>> Dana Levin: We found
a definition.
It's all theoretical.
>> Ron Charles: Your
first book begins
with a really weird
poem, Lenin's Bath.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: That was
a daring, daring choice.
Do I have the right one?
Yeah. I'd also like to know
why you opened with that poem.
>> Dana Levin: Oh I felt like -
>> Ron Charles: Nobody
knows who you are.
You're publishing your first
book and you open with this poem.
>> Dana Levin: I think it's because
it just set the terms for the book.
>> Ron Charles: I think it sets
the terms for your whole career.
You couldn't have done that then.
>> Dana Levin: I didn't, no.
So this poem, it's called
Lenin's Bath and it came out of -
this book was published in1999,
but a lot of the poems were
written between the late 80's.
No, like early 90's and the
wall had just barely come down;
so all these things were happening
and the former Soviet Union
like what do we do with Lenin's body
that's been embalmed forever and is
like in this mausoleum and there was
some article in the New York Times
that talked about the doctor whose
job it was to care for Lenin's body
and it was pretty fascinating to me
that they had kept this body
going for I don't know -
>> Ron Charles: Decades.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: In
really good shape.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah,
well, oh my God.
>> Ron Charles: They
spent so much money on it.
>> Dana Levin: Poor Lenin.
Poor, sad Lenin.
And there was a quote in the
article, the future of the body,
that's a purely political question.
Which I found fascinating
at the time
because no, at least not this body.
So it's called Lenin's Bath.
The assistants lift
him gently, gently.
For a moment, the one lifting
under his arms is in the attitude
of an artistic sorrow--
It is the Deposition,
the taking own of the God.
But then one of them wraps his
limp body around him like a coat,
marches around to the laughter,
saying, "Comrades, comrades--
" He is dead, he is so dead he is
nothing, he is a cloth to tend.
When Debov walks in,
disheveled, yawning,
the assistants are all
business, filling the vat
with the secret fluid that makes
him supple, that makes him clean.
They are so tender,
lowering him into the tub.
Their gloved hands
come away fleshy pink.
When they've gone,
Debov sits watching.
He imagines the sheath of bacteria
he knows is there, incessant,
biological, seeking a way in.
They push and gather at every pore,
but the flesh is sealed-- His doing.
Soaking in his vat of embalming
fluid, Lenin looks restful,
meditative, a high official
in his bath in his dacha,
far away from the controlled
air of the mausoleum,
the schoolchildren filing
past him unblinking,
the veterans who stand,
expressionless.
Debov watches as the germs crawl
up and down the length of the body,
scouring, sniffing
for that open hole--
The cold windows in the laboratory
condense with his breath,
and the flies lie hungry
in the snow.
>> Ron Charles: It works so well
because it raises this issue
about what is the body and
how does it relate to identity
in a very macabre,
comic way in this poem.
And then other poems
it's very serious.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Why is that
such a compelling issue for you?
>> Dana Levin: I've never
felt at home in my body.
My body has been a
source of difficulty
for me both physically
and aesthetically.
You know and women
we have this issue.
We never look like what the
magazines tell us we should
look like.
We - you know that kind
of stuff, but I think also
when I was born my mother - my
mother was actually the first woman
in California to have amniocentesis.
So actually she was in an - like
one of those operating theaters
where all those people
were like watching,
so even then in the
womb I was like -
anyway it's something
called Rh factor.
So her body was treating
me like an invader.
So they had to induce labor.
I was born at eight months.
I weighed four pounds.
I immediately started to die.
They didn't know exactly what
it was, but they knew it was one
of my vital organs; so
they basically just opened
up from sternum to pelvis and
they took out part of my intestine
and I had a colostomy bad for
the first two years of my life.
And I was in an incubator
for two months, sorry -
for the first two months of my life.
And I've got these scars
all over my stomach still.
And I've got scars on my
ankles from where they fed me.
They put a feeding
tube in my ankles.
And my nails and my teeth
are screwed up because
of how many antibiotics they
gave me when I was that little.
And so - and then alter in
life you know, just discovering
that like certain posture issues,
like a musculoskeletal issues
actually stem from that
because of how deep they cut in
and so the body has been difficult.
And also a story like when I was
a kid and I'd be like you know,
my parents would tell me the
story of what happened to me,
and it was like hearing a
tale about someone else.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dana Levin: Because I
wasn't expected to live.
>> Ron Charles: Our
bodies are us, but not us.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah and you know you
just realize incarnation is probably
the most heroic thing
any of us can accomplish.
Because it is really hard
in here wouldn't you agree?
And so, I think that there's
also a dissociative quality
to my personality that maybe
comes from some of that too
where the spirit really wants to get
as far away from this as possible.
And then I tell my students I
- I say the beginning of art
and religion is the first time
aug found oog dead on the ground
and went "oog" like wake up
and there's no oog in there.
And Aug is like, wow where'd he go.
Cause there's his body but
whatever he was is not in there.
That's it, that's the beginning.
>> Ron Charles: Paul
[Inaudible] Allen.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: This
is what I meant by one
of the darker, it's not comic poems.
But this [Inaudible]
and the identity.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah so when
I was in grad school at NYU,
Sharon Olds had started
an amazing program
at Goldwater Hospital
on Roosevelt Island.
And Goldwater Hospital, if my memory
is serving me correctly was either
city run or state run
like nursing home,
so the people that were there didn't
have - I don't think they had money.
There were all sorts of people there
who were - had all sorts of problems
with their body from you
know OD's that had gone wrong
and messed somebody up to people
with really debilitating
degenerative diseases.
So, she started this writing program
for the patients at Goldwater
and the grad students at NYU had
an opportunity to work with them.
And you would - there
was a workshop,
some of them couldn't speak, some
of them were using letter boards.
Some of them were just present and
you couldn't necessarily even tell
if they were participating
or not, but they were there.
And then you would sometimes come
on different days to transcribe.
And Paul Ruseau, he spelled his
name like the French Philosopher
but a nurse later told me his
last name was really R-U-S-S-O.
I don't know what his physical - I
don't know what his diagnosis was
but he was in a wheelchair
and he could not hold a pen.
But he wrote reams
and reams of poems.
I mean I went into his
room at the hospital
and there were just
drawers full of poems.
And I helped him as best I could
for the time that I was there.
And they were good poems.
And I remember one time just hanging
out with him eating
Easter candy, you know?
And so anyway, this is Paul.
Paul Roosevelt Island.
The broken teeth, the ulcers,
eating into the backs of people
who have spent years sitting in
chairs, in the green tiled halls
of a hospital, trying to find a
place to read, to think, to find,
like Faye, a place to turn one's
back and cry, to say, like Faye,
When I cry I know it is Jesus
crying, because Jesus is
in my chest, he's crying
for me, for my cut-off legs,
he's crying for you Paul, your feet
bent like his, your bones stuck
like nails through the flesh of your
body, pinning you to a wheelchair
for twenty-three years, your hands
shaped like claws, skin-hard,
tremoring, your shirt covered
with egg yolk and coffee,
your green pants stained with
pus and shit- and the doctors,
gliding by you like sails, saying
Hello, Hello, as you open the stink
of your plaque-caked mouth and
say Hello, you are beautiful,
your soft eyes, your old
man smell, the way you stick
out your clawed hand to shake mine
and say Thank you, popping chocolate
in your mouth when we shared Easter
candy, the dull brown saliva falling
in torrents because you couldn't
stop talking about poetry Paul.
I see you in a wheelchair, on the
weed strewn windswept eastside
of the island, the Pepsi sign
curling over the banks of Queens,
the clouds rolling black in from the
Hudson, and you are saying Yes, now,
I am giving myself up to the
wind, I am a kite, I am a bird,
I am weightless and beyond
gravity, slipping up and diffusing,
the million captive particles of me
falling like mist over the hospital,
because I am wholly
mind, wholly air,
I am dropping these
wrecked bone shackles.
[ Applause ]
>> Dana Levin: I should
write my first book again.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah,
we're all eventually Paul.
We all eventually want to get out
of our ruined bodies by the end.
>> Dana Levin: We do.
I have a lot to say about
what we do with our elderly
and dying in this country.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah, I am
wholly mind he says in the end.
Wholly air.
I'm dropping these
wrecked bone shackles.
That's an ancient idea before
Christianity of course,
adopted this Paul was
very much into that idea,
but it started before him, right?
The idea of the spirit
and the mind that the body
and the identity were somehow
at odds with one another
and would eventually
be separated again.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah, it's
tough because sometimes I feel
like they took it way too far
the Judao Christians in terms
of like the body is evil, you should
just be focusing on your spirit.
But we have to figure
out how to be in here.
I mean we have to figure
out how to do this.
I don't think it's about
not doing this, you know?
I think it's about how do I have
a mind, and how do I have a body.
>> Ron Charles: Right you
ask in one of your poems,
do you think this is repulsive?
You're sort of daring us.
Yeah. And another poem about
being drawn to a movie theater.
It's obviously about much more.
You speak of the great relief
of just not being in the world,
just being able to watch.
The lights go off and you're not
you anymore, you're just as you say
to give up the burden awhile,
to be an eye, perceiver,
God of the Kingdom, to
have that emersonian moment
where you're just the eye,
the transparent eyeball.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah for a long time
that was my biggest goal in life -
>> Ron Charles: Was to
be a transparent eyeball?
>> Dana Levin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: It - do you have
that disembodied perspective
in another poem you
right and the poet says
"You may not admit to bone or flesh.
You must not have nerves
in the tip of your fingers.
You may say fist, you may say
teeth but you may not put them
in the same sentence together.
You must not put them
in the body together".
You're obviously mocking
that idea in a way.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: The opening
poem of banana palace,
your latest book contains
these lines "We had a dream
that we could smash the bands of
matter and time and still be alive.
Was that the soul wishing we would
invent the body out of existence?
So many of us now enthralled
by doom".
>> Ron Charles: Let's stand up,
turn around and sit back down.
>> Ron Charles: Dmitry Itskov.
>> Dana Levin: Itskov.
>> Ron Charles: That is a
funny poem, what a weird guy.
>> Dana Levin: Oh yeah.
>> Ron Charles: That's not
a real person you'd read
about in the newspaper right?
>> Dana Levin: Actually that
poem is a big faker because all
of the lines were stolen from
articles in the New York Times
and Huffington Post except
for line four through six.
>> Ron Charles: That's not
a faker; that's amazing.
That is amazing.
Wait till you hear this poem.
This strange young man wants
to basically translate
himself into a machine.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
He's a billionaire.
He's a Russian billionaire.
He's spending all of his
money trying to figure out how
to download consciousness
into mechanical bodies.
>> Ron Charles: So he's the -
it's sort of a non-religious
pursuit of this Pauline idea.
>> Dana Levin: Well you know
he's interesting to read about.
He says it's the cure for hunger,
it's the cure for so
many of our ills.
And I can intellectually understand
but I think there is a
great spiritual purpose
to being incarnated and we're
just endlessly trying to figure
out ways not to have to have
it, not to have to do it.
And this is - so anyway
Dmitry Itskov Cento.
Cento is a poem form where you take
lines from others and build a poem.
So I took lines from an article in
the Huffington Post and an article
in the New York Times
and I reorganized them
and lightly edited them and
then the lines that I wrote are
at the eye level, this
is like a cyborg poem.
Anyway, Dmitry Itskov:A Cento.
Dmitry Itskov, 32, has a
colossal dream: an early start
for his own mechanical face.
He's one of the men with
brains, wondering how,
to evade the death
of meat, he thinks.
By 2045 we'll have
substance independent minds,
the no need for biology at all.
At 25, he started to have the
symptoms of a midlife crisis.
The musical instruments
unlearned, the books unread,
the more he contemplated the
world, the more broken it seemed.
"What we're doing here does not
look like the behavior of grown-ups,
killing the planet and
killing ourselves."
Decoupling the mind from the needy
human body could pave the way
for a more sublime human spirit.
It could allow paralyzed
people to communicate,
or control a robotic
arm or a wheelchair.
It could allow you to start your
car if you think, "Start my car".
Within a century, we'll
frequent "body service shops,"
choose our bodies from a catalogue,
then transfer our consciousness
to one better suited
for life on Mars.
"From the very beginning," he said,
"we realized Dmitry was
not an ordinary person."
He leads a life that could
best be described as monastic.
No meat, fish, coffee,
alcohol, or cold water.
Meat gives him an energy
he's "not comfortable with."
What is the brain?
What is consciousness?
It contains plenty of terrifying,
brink-of-extinction plot twists.
It's somewhere between a
cellphone call and teleportation.
It's speaking with his
voice in real time.
Get right up close to Dmitry
Itskov and sniff all you like.
He has the kind of generically
handsome face and perfect smile
that seem computer generated,
complete with all the particulars
of consciousness and personality.
Yes, we have seen this movie
and yes, it always leads
to robots enslaving humanity.
For now, just acquiring a
lifelike robotic head is a splurge.
It's - someone from the
New York Times wrote that.
>> Ron Charles: To
evade the death of meat.
That's pretty much -
>> Dana Levin: I wrote that one.
>> Ron Charles: The ideal of
almost all the religions on earth.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Another poem, you
have the line "You believe in skin",
which has such a great
double meaning.
You believe that skin exists
and we believe in our skins.
Our belief takes place in -
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Sky Barrow ends
with a poem about a weird farm.
>> Dana Levin: It's a real place.
>> Ron Charles: I saw the
footnote and went back
and read the article in the Times.
This is a farm where
they study forensics
by letting actual bodies
rot in the fields.
They take pictures of them and they
study how they decompose over time,
so they can solve murders
where they find bodies
that have been decomposing
over time.
And you decided to write a poem, I
won't even go into what that means.
>> Dana Levin: My perfect scenario.
I read the same article.
Yeah it's called the Body Farm.
It's graduate school for
forensic anthropology
at the University of
Tennessee-Knoxville.
And I have to say that when
you read the article the guy
who runs it is a weird dude.
>> Ron Charles: Oh very.
>> Dana Levin: Where
he's - you know he's -
or the writer made him
a weird - he's strange.
>> Ron Charles: No he's weird.
>> Dana Levin: Artist
of death, I don't know.
Anyway -
>> Ron Charles: He's wandering
around actual rotting bodies
and saying things like
"It's beautiful to me".
>> Dana Levin: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, honeybees -
so this poem is called
Spring, you should imagine
that you are a graduate
student in this program
and you are going to do homework.
The sun, in shafts and spades.
Through the pine and birches,
little setting off the leaves.
Their golden green increase.
Pollen to the air, its colonial
dream of a new imperium of trees.
Snap against the wrist-skin.
And then you press down on the
tongue with your gloved thumb
to let the honeybee
show you the way.
The dark tunnel paths
from light to light.
Flay the face and scoop
out the eyes - you'll see.
Bees in a cloud round your hand.
Egg-herder, your smell
synonymous with treasure.
Shining a light at the
back of the throat.
Blowflies in liquid pearls,
the bees murder to eat.
And all at the ips and nose a yellow
dust, pollen they have delivered.
You scrape it into a little sack.
Ripple and snap.
Bend to the O of the
rigored mouth - listen.
>>Dana Levin: Plastic bags,
like souls, caught in trees.
What to harvest from the
sloughed-off suits of the dead.
Like seashells cupping the
ghost-tongue of the sea,
their black mouths speak.
You crouch to the hum
with a bag and a blade.
You the God it sways.
>> Ron Charles: The line from
your first poem in your first book
to what is also the
last poem in that book.
People caring for bodies,
one body being preserved
at the tremendous expense
and almost insane effort
and these bodies being left
purposely to rot in the open.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Makes us think
about what we really are physically.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: And
where the we resides.
>> Dana Levin: Yes, yeah.
Yeah and you know it's
interesting when I was working
on Banana Palace the book
that Dmitry Itskov is from,
I was like oh, finally I'm writing
about technology and I'm writing
about end times and I'm writing
about anxiety about the future.
And then really late in the
game I was like "Oh my God,
I'm still writing about the body.
I'm still writing about the body".
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Dana Levin: I think I'll probably
always write about the body.
>> Ron Charles: I want to talk about
angels because they have bodies
but they're also immaterial.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: So they're a weird
answer to the paradox in your poems.
This one called the nurse.
If you'd read that poem.
>> Dana Levin: Sure.
>> Dana Levin: To tell you
the truth, I don't even know
where this idea and image came from.
>> Ron Charles: It's kind of
comforting and lovely to imagine
that the operating room
is filled with angels.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah but, okay.
The Nurse.
There are so many now, perched
on the headboard, opening
and closing their wings like moths.
The kidney is failing,
and so many are arriving,
alighting on the blanket,
the pillow,
falling around the comatose patient,
settling in drifts
against the paper gown.
You've been seeing this, you've
been watching them gather,
you've told no one how the buzzing
keeps growing around the bed.
Now they crowd like a sea around
the body, listing and pushing,
the pulse of their wings lifting the
current, you can feel it, the wind,
on the hairs of your arms, making
the lamp sway, ruffling the chart
at the foot of the bed,
they are hanging from tubes,
perched on the monitor, pressing
and pressing with a rising hum,
you can hear it, the whirring, the
din of their waiting, as they rustle
and jostle and launch with a
roar, a roar of angels swarming
over the body, burrowing
headfirst into every pore.
>> Ron Charles: That's comforting.
Yeah I heard an angel
buzz when I died.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Later in the book
you reject the idea of angels.
>> Dana Levin: Oh yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Very
interesting way.
It's called banishing angels.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: It's like you
considered angels as an answer
to this problem and then you
realized angels are not the answer.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah well you
know I was writing a lot of this
but while living in New York
City and if anything is going
to make you realize the
incontrovertible fact of bodies,
it's living in New York City.
>> Ron Charles: The
presence of everyone.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Such a crown.
>> Dana Levin: And that there's
beauty and amazingness there.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Dana Levin: You know,
Banishing the angels.
And then the cloud passed and a
light came rushing down the steps
of the subway and blazed
up against the phone booth,
standing in the corner.
And inside it was a girl
talking on the phone,
all lit up amid the
grime of the subway.
And when I saw her I
wanted her to be an angel.
I wanted her with wings inside
the station to say the angel
on the phone, and see
it softly beating.
Old newspapers at its feet and
no one noticing, white and gold
in the dirty class, blazing
religious in the piss and exhaust
and oddity bright in the
light of the phone booth.
And angel in a box in the
filtered sun where I was straining
to look back at the light
rushing down at the girl
who was not an angel
talking on the phone.
In the real light of the
unmystical sun thinking the girl
who is not an angel is
something to believe.
The phone booth in the
sunlight, something to believe.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
So that's your answer.
It's your reject all that
metaphysical abstraction and goo
and just say this is the world.
This physical world is what
we have to - what we have
and we have to love and appreciate.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
This is why somebody
like Dmitry Itskov.
I'm like this is what you
want to do with your billions?
This is it, or anybody that's
trying to figure out how
to extend our lifespan or make us
immortal, what a waste of resources.
We're not supposed to be here
for a long time, I don't think.
>> Ron Charles: There's beauty
in what we have and what we are.
>> Dana Levin: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: That's a really,
I love the way the poem moves
too so quickly like that.
>> Ron Charles: I want to talk
about - we are winding down.
I want to talk about a larger
kind of death that you approach
in this poem called - we'll
call it banana palace.
It's a long poem.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: But we
are near the end here.
>> Dana Levin: Okay so
should I give background?
>> Ron Charles: Yeah,
whatever we would need.
>> Dana Levin: There's a lot in this
book that is addressing our world
of social media, which is
really only 10 years old,
shocking to recall.
I don't even think we
understand what it's doing to us.
Many gifts, many not gifts.
So, I was trolling
through Facebook one day,
and then all of a sudden
"what is that"?
And I saw this image and I
just was like "What is that"?
And it made me stop.
And I looked at it
and it was beautiful
and then I saw what it was.
And I really wanted to write about
this image but I didn't know how
to write about it without
writing about Facebook,
which just seemed very
dismal subject.
Hi Facebook streaming.
It just seemed like a really,
really dismal subject for poetry.
So I let it go for a year and then
I was like I really want to write
about this image, but apparently how
can I write about its effect on me
if I don't write about the way that
it popped up out of the narcotic
of just kind of going
like this, you know?
And then I was like all right,
how are you going to do this?
Why would you write about Facebook?
To tell people about it.
Well who doesn't know about it?
Well obviously somebody who was born
after the collapse of civilization
and had no sense of where we are.
So once I hit upon that, I
was able to write this poem.
So, the speaker of the poem is
somebody who has lived in our time
and has also gone through what we
might call apocalypse survivable
and is now on the other side.
And is trying to describe to
somebody who has never lived
in our world about this
image and about Facebook.
And at the end of the poem it
will reveal what this image was.
The very first part of this
poem, the speaker is both me
and this figure, this made up
figure of apocalypse survivor
but then pretty soon
it's just the survivor.
>> Ron Charles: Which
could be you someday.
>> Dana Levin: I don't know.
As I have said many times
I think my only hope is
if you decide I am the Shaman krone
woman that you are going to carry
around and I will dispense wisdom
in exchange for food because I'm old
and overweight and out of shape
and all I know how to do is this.
>> Ron Charles: We'll need that.
>> Dana Levin: Okay.
Banana Palace.
I want you to know how it felt to
hold it, deep in the well of my eye.
You, future person: star of
one of my complicated doom.
This one's called Back to the Dark.
Scene 1: Death stampedes
through the server-cities.
Somehow we all end up living in
caves, foraging in civic ruin.
Banana Palace?-?the last
of the last of my kind
who can read breathes it hot
into your doom-rimed ear.
She's a dowser of spine-broken
books and loose paper the rest
of your famishing band thinks mad.
Mine was the era of
spending your time
in town squares made out of air.
You invented a face
and moved it around,
visited briefly with other faces.
Thus we streamed down lit
screens sharing pictures
of animals looking ridiculous.
Trading portals to
shoes, love, songs, news,
somebody's latest rabid cause:
bosses, gluten, bacon, God.
Information about information
was the pollen we deposited,
while in the real fields
bees starved.
Into this noise sailed
Banana Palace.
It was a mother ship of gold.
Shining out between
HAPPY BDAY KATIE!
And a photo of someone's broken toe.
Like luminous pillows
cocked on a hinge,
like a house with a heavy lid, a
round house of platelets and honey.
It was open, like a
box that holds a ring.
And inside, where the ring would be.
>> Dana Levin: I think about
you a lot, future person.
How you will need all the
books that were ever read
when the screens and wires go dumb.
Whatever you haven't used
for kindling or bedding.
Whatever made it through
the fuckcluster
of bombs we launched accidentally,
at the end of the era of feeling
like no one was doing a thing
about our complicated dooms.
Helpless and braced we sat in
dark spaces submerged in pools
of projected images, trying
to disappear into light.
Light! There was so much light!
It was hard to sleep.
Anyway. Banana Palace.
Even now when I say it,
cymbals shiver out in spheres.
It starts to turn its yellow
gears and opens like a clam.
Revealing a fetal curl on its
temple floor, bagged and sleeping.
A white cocoon under lit strings
that stretch from floor to ceiling.
A harp made of glass
incubating a covered pearl.
We broke the world you're
living in, future person.
Maybe that was always our end:
to break the jungles to get
at the sugar, leave
behind a waste of cane.
There came a time I couldn't look at
trees without feeling elegiac?-?as
if nature were already over,
if you know what I mean.
It was the most glorious
thing I had ever seen.
Cross-section of a banana under
a microscope the caption read.
I hunched around my little screen
sharing a fruit no one could eat.
>> Ron Charles: The book itself
ends with a poet in a cave trying
to conjure up a peach with poetry.
>> Dana Levin: Yes.
It's foolish.
And it's a shot out to proof rock.
>> Ron Charles: Oh
that's excellent, yeah.
That works well.
>> Dana Levin: They're
Elliott's all in there.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
That's so typical of your work.
It's quite grim and quite
funny at the same time.
>> Dana Levin: I think
it's my Jewish background.
I like black humor.
I mean you know this world is a
veil of tears, it's hilarious.
>> Ron Charles: It's been such
a pleasure to talk to you;
you're just a fascinating writer.
Thank you so much.
>> Dana Levin: Thank
you; thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.